[Música]
vamos a las noticias de la economía con
Juan Pablo lucum y Juan Pablo Buenos
días para usted Buenos días Ángela un
gusto estar de vuelta Igualmente Juan
Pablo y lo hacemos este retorno de usted
a las mañanas con una noticia que ya se
venía anticipando una de las grandes
economías mundiales entra en recesión
Ángela pues desde finales de 2022
empezamos a hablar de un panorama de
recesión que aquí lo estuvimos revisando
y un panorama que llegó hasta inicio de
este año porque las grandes economías
Pues de todo el mundo estaban teniendo
de que llegara la recesión y este
espacio ya llegó a Alemania nada más y
nada menos que la principal Economía del
continente europeo recordemos que un
país cae en recesión técnica cuando por
dos trimestres consecutivos reporta una
contracción y si nos vamos a las cifras
en el último trimestre de 2022 el
producto interno bruto de Alemania se
contrajo un 0,5% y este primer trimestre
acumuló su segunda contracción con una
caída del 0,3% es decir el último
trimestre en negativo Este primer
trimestre nos da igual que una recesión
técnica el ministro de finanzas alemán
dijo que los datos del pib mostraron
señales sorprendentemente negativas y
que él no quiere que Alemania juegue en
una liga en la que se tengan que relegar
a las últimas posiciones Bueno pero la
economía es muy cambiante Juan Pablo y
hay un panorama completamente opuesto
también en Europa pero con los
resultados industriales en España Vamos
hasta España porque hablamos de los
precios industriales en los últimos 12
meses hasta abril que registraron su
caída más pronunciada desde julio 2020
según los datos entregados por el
Instituto Nacional de estadística este
jueves los precios industriales cayeron
un 4,5% respecto al mismo mes del año
anterior lo que supone una caída mayor
que la disminución interanual del 1,4%
de marzo los precios de la energía
fueron los que lideraron el descenso con
una contracción del
5,9%, esto debido a que los precios de
la electricidad los productos refinados
del petróleo y el gas cayeron los
precios de los bienes intermedios
también tuvieron una disminución durante
ese período en el escenario
inflacionario de España también pues
muestra buenos resultados pues la
inflación anual en el período hasta
abril fue el 4,1% por debajo del máximo
del 10,8 interanual del verano pasado
exactamente en julio lo que quiere decir
que también hay un descenso ahí usted
nos hablaba de energía y ese es un tema
El que deberíamos prestar especial
atención Juan Pablo y hablamos del más
reciente informe de la agencia
internacional de energía que le espera
al mundo en términos energéticos
revisemos Entonces los números porque la
agencia dice que las inversiones de
Carbón mundiales están en camino a
aumentar cerca de un 10% este año es
decir casi seis veces más de lo que la
entidad ha estimado que debería ser para
que el mundo ponga fin a su dependencia
de los combustibles fósiles y logren los
objetivos de reducción para las
emisiones de emisiones para
contrarrestar el cambio climático en los
números se Espera que se inviertan 2,8
billones de dólares en energía a nivel
mundial en 2023 de los cuales un poco
más de un billón se espera pues este
destinado al carbón el gas y el petróleo
es decir combustibles fósiles que son
una fuente importante de misiones que
contribuyen al calentamiento global la
inversión global destinada a tecnologías
limpias es mayor con un 1,7 billones de
dólares en la que están incluidas las
redes eléctricas modernas el
almacenamiento de energía los
combustibles de bajas emisiones y los
vehículos eléctricos pero pese a todo
esto Esta inversión en energías limpias
pues la agencia considera que el dinero
para el carbón todavía sigue siendo
demasiado cerramos entonces con esta
cita de team Wood que es economista jefe
de la energía de la agencia
internacional
que dice estamos en un lugar
significativamente mejor que hace unos
años todavía hay un largo camino por
recorrer pero finalmente hay algunas
señales alentadoras para que todos demos
la bienvenida como quien dice se está
invirtiendo en limpias pero todavía
demasiado dinero para el carbón bien
Juan Pablo le pido que vayamos a América
Latina en Ecuador el presidente
Guillermo lasso ha decretado una nueva
ley de inversiones y de zonas francas en
las condiciones especiales en las que se
encuentra el país ahora Ángela se trata
de un decreto un segundo decreto pues
emitido por lazo luego de que el pasado
17 de mayo firmara la denominada muerte
Cruzada que le permitió disolver el
parlamento y Llamar a elecciones
anticipadas que ya hoy conocimos las
fechas hablamos de la ley de atracción y
fomento de inversiones para el
desarrollo productivo que busca reducir
los costos de producción y generar más
empleo según lo dijo el presidente
ecuatoriano la normativa menciona al
desarrollo económico de zonas
fronterizas de Colombia y Perú sugiere
exonerar del impuesto a la renta por 10
años a los inversores y por más de 15
años a quienes lo hagan en zonas de
frontera El decreto plantea la extensión
de tributos al comercio exterior Excepto
a las tasas por servicios aduaneros para
importación de insumos vienes de capital
y materias primas destinadas a la zona
franca tenemos ya algo de indicadores no
Así es vamos a ver cómo está el panorama
general en las bolsas nuevamente la
mayoría de acciones de las bolsas de
América Latina retrocedieron al cierre
de la jornada y llevaron a que los
mercados cierren en rojo con la
excepción de las plazas de Argentina y
México que cerraron en positivo dentro
de los indicadores que más retrocedieron
está el de Brasil y Perú pues y entre
estos por varios escenarios que ya
veremos también en la segunda Crónica
con más información por ejemplo de
Colombia el cierre de Asia se dio mixto
con Tokio con ganancias del 0,39% y Hong
Kong con pérdidas del
1,93%. las bolsas europeas siguen
operando en su mayoría con pérdidas
luego de conocerse que Alemania entró en
recesión técnica lo que muestra el
estado de la primera Economía del
continente
me trajo cifra del día así es esa cifra
ya la conocimos Durante los informativos
pero la vamos a detallar aquí son los
606 mil las 600 6000 personas que pues
esta fue la migración neta anual de
Reino Unido en 2022 lo que supone un
número récord según la oficina para
estadísticas nacionales británicas el
aumento fue impulsado por ciudadanos no
pertenecientes a la Unión Europea
refugiados bajo la visa de pues Ucrania
bajo el también el gobierno británico
así como las personas que migran para
trabajar y estudiar según el Primer
Ministro Richie sunak este número es
demasiado alto muy lejos de los
objetivos que se han trazado los
gobiernos pues pasados de tener una
migración por lo menos de 100.000
personas netas todavía el número
bastante lejos Este es un reto y el otro
reto es de reducir la inflación a la
mitad y se siguen acumulando gobiernos
conservadores que prometen bajar la
migración sin tener éxito no lo logran
gracias a ustedes Juan Pablo y nos vemos
más tarde ahora con mucho masaje